bem-vindo de volta a entendendo informação e computação quântica, meu nome é John Watrous e sou o diretor técnico de educação da IBM Quantum
esta é a 13ª aula da série e é a primeira aula da quarta e última unidade, que trata de correção de erros quânticos
a computação quântica tem o potencial de viabilizar soluções eficientes para tarefas computacionais para as quais
algoritmos clássicos eficientes não são conhecidos e possivelmente não existem; existem, porém, desafios muito significativos que
precisarão ser superados se quisermos implementar os tipos de computações quânticas em larga escala que esperamos que um dia sejam
possíveis o cerne da questão é que a informação quântica é extremamente frágil — você pode literalmente arruiná-la simplesmente
olhando para ela e, portanto, para funcionar corretamente, computadores quânticos precisam isolar a informação quântica que
armazenam do ambiente ao redor de maneira extrema, mas ao mesmo tempo o próprio computador quântico precisa nos fornecer
controle muito preciso sobre essa informação quântica, o que inclui inicialização adequada, operações
unitárias precisas e confiáveis e, claro, a capacidade de realizar medições para que possamos de fato obter os resultados da
computação há claramente uma tensão entre esses requisitos e nos primórdios da computação quântica havia quem acreditasse que a fragilidade
da informação quântica e sua suscetibilidade tanto a imprecisões quanto a ruídos ambientais acabaria
tornando a computação quântica impossível hoje há pouca dúvida de que construir um computador quântico
grande e confiável é um desafio monumental, mas temos uma ferramenta fundamental para nos ajudar nessa empreitada, que leva a maioria
das pessoas que conhecem o campo a ser otimista sobre a computação quântica em larga escala um dia se tornar realidade, e essa ferramenta é a correção de erros quânticos
nas próximas quatro aulas discutiremos a correção de erros quânticos com foco nos
fundamentos nesta aula faremos uma primeira abordagem da correção de erros quânticos, incluindo um dos primeiros
códigos de correção de erros quânticos descobertos — o código de Shor de 9 qubits — e também discutiremos outro conceito fundamental em
correção de erros quânticos, conhecido como a discretização de erros nas aulas subsequentes da unidade veremos construções de códigos de correção de erros quânticos mais sofisticadas e, em última análise, melhores
e também discutiremos o problema da computação quântica sobre informação quântica codificada usando
componentes computacionais que não são perfeitos e estão sujeitos a erros aqui está uma breve visão geral da
aula vamos começar discutindo os códigos de repetição clássicos, que são talvez o tipo mais simples e básico
de código clássico de correção de erros os códigos de repetição clássicos não são códigos particularmente bons pelos
padrões da teoria clássica de codificação, pelo menos por conta própria, mas tudo bem — aqui buscamos simplicidade e, em particular,
vamos dar uma olhada no código de correção de erros clássico mais simples que você consegue imaginar, que vamos usar como base para um exemplo simples
de código de correção de erros quânticos esse exemplo é o código de Shor de 9 qubits, que discutiremos em detalhes
incluindo uma descrição do próprio código, bem como procedimentos para codificar qubits com esse código, detectar erros em qubits codificados e
corrigir esses erros e na terceira parte da aula discutiremos a discretização de erros, que nos permite pensar sobre erros arbitrários em
qubits — que em princípio formam um continuum de possibilidades — em termos discretos, reduzindo essencialmente os erros a
chamados bit flips e phase flips antes de entrar nos detalhes técnicos da correção de erros quânticos, vale
a pena parar um momento para considerar a necessidade da correção de erros quânticos, bem como da correção de erros clássicos
como sugeri no início da aula, computadores quânticos são altamente suscetíveis a erros devido à
fragilidade da informação quântica em particular, interações indesejadas com o ambiente ou, em
outras palavras, o restante do mundo pode perturbar a informação quântica essas interações indesejadas podem causar decoerência, onde a informação
essencialmente vaza para o ambiente, fazendo com que a informação armazenada pelo computador quântico se comporte cada vez mais
de forma clássica também é de extrema importância reconhecer que operações quânticas só podem ser realizadas com
precisão limitada por exemplo, podemos querer aplicar um gate quântico específico a um qubit, mas porque dispositivos físicos nunca são
perfeitos, o que realmente implementamos pode ser apenas uma aproximação desse gate, o que pode não ser grande problema para um
único gate, mas se nossa intenção é executar milhares ou milhões de gates quânticos, essas pequenas imprecisões vão
começar a se acumular e, ao final da computação, podemos acabar com um estado muito diferente do que
esperávamos portanto, essa é uma fonte de erros bem diferente, mas certamente uma que não podemos
ignorar as pessoas vêm estudando códigos clássicos de correção de erros há quase um século, e esses códigos têm muitas aplicações, incluindo em
transmissão e armazenamento de informação, mas como os componentes da computação clássica são muito confiáveis, não precisamos
de correção de erros para construir computadores clássicos agora pode ser que a correção de erros também não seja necessária
para construir computadores quânticos grandes e confiáveis; por exemplo, a ideia principal por trás da computação quântica topológica
é que pode ser possível construir sistemas quânticos robustos que sejam inerentemente protegidos contra ruídos devido
a propriedades topológicas dos sistemas, mas não sabemos se isso será possível e é bastante amplamente acreditado
que a correção de erros provavelmente será essencial de alguma forma para a computação quântica em larga escala agora vamos discutir os códigos de repetição clássicos
que formam a base para nosso primeiro código de correção de erros quânticos — o código de Shor de 9 qubits — que
veremos em breve os códigos de repetição são exemplos extremamente básicos de códigos de correção de erros
a ideia é que podemos proteger bits contra erros simplesmente repetindo cada bit um certo número de vezes; em particular, vamos dar uma olhada em
o código de repetição de três bits aqui codificamos um bit em três simplesmente repetindo o bit três vezes, então
zero é codificado como 000 e um é codificado como 111; claro, se nada der errado,
podemos distinguir facilmente as duas possibilidades, mas se houver um erro e um dos bits for invertido —
significando que um zero muda para um ou um muda para zero — ainda podemos descobrir qual era o bit original
vendo qual dos dois valores binários aparece duas vezes; equivalentemente, podemos decodificar calculando o valor majoritário
ou seja, o valor binário que aparece com mais frequência, e não é difícil ver que
se tivermos no máximo um erro de bit flip, a decodificação estará correta; claro, se dois bits forem invertidos ou se
todos os três bits forem invertidos, não vai funcionar e obteremos o valor errado ao decodificar, e essa é uma propriedade geral
que todo código de correção de erros possui: você pode ser capaz de corrigir alguns erros, mas nunca vai conseguir corrigir todos os erros e, em última análise,
trata-se de diminuir a chance de um erro em vez de garantir a correção, o que geralmente não é
possível como exemplo de uma situação em que podemos diminuir a chance de cometer um erro, vamos supor que nosso
objetivo é comunicar um único bit a um receptor hipotético e, para isso, podemos transmitir bits por um
canal chamado canal binário simétrico, que inverte cada bit enviado por ele independentemente com alguma probabilidade
P; assim, com probabilidade 1 menos P, o receptor obterá o bit que pretendíamos enviar, mas com probabilidade P
o bit é invertido e o receptor recebe o valor oposto ao que enviamos; portanto, se não usarmos o código de repetição
e simplesmente enviarmos o bit desejado pelo canal, o receptor receberá o bit errado com
probabilidade P; por outro lado, se primeiro codificarmos o bit que queremos enviar usando o código de repetição de três bits e
depois enviarmos cada um dos três bits da codificação pelo canal, então cada um deles é invertido com probabilidade P, então
as chances de um bit flip são agora maiores porque há três bits que podem ser invertidos em vez de um
mas se no máximo um dos bits for invertido, o receptor conseguirá decodificar corretamente, então só teremos um erro após
a decodificação se dois ou mais bits forem invertidos durante a transmissão, e não é muito difícil calcular que isso acontece com
probabilidade 3 * P² - 2 * P³; para valores de P menores que 1/12
isso leva a uma diminuição na probabilidade de o receptor receber o bit errado; ainda haverá uma chance de erro nesse caso, mas o
código diminui essa probabilidade, e se você quiser diminuir a chance ainda mais, pode fazer isso usando um
código diferente, incluindo, mas não se limitando a, a possibilidade de usar um código de repetição onde o bit codificado é repetido
mais de três vezes; para valores de P maiores que 1/12, aliás, o código na verdade piora
as coisas no sentido de que aumenta a probabilidade de o receptor receber o bit errado, então certamente não usaríamos esse código nessa
situação o código de repetição de três bits é um código clássico de correção de erros, mas também podemos considerar o que acontece se
tentarmos usá-lo para proteger qubits contra erros; não é um código de correção de erros quânticos muito bom, como veremos
ele pode corrigir alguns erros, mas torna outros erros mais prováveis; é, no entanto, o primeiro passo em direção ao código de Shor
então vamos ver como ele funciona para qubits; primeiro, para ser claro, quando nos referimos ao código de repetição de 3 bits sendo usado
para qubits, o que temos em mente é uma codificação de um qubit conforme mostrado na tela, onde Alpha|0⟩ mais beta|1⟩
é codificado como Alpha|000⟩ mais beta|111⟩, ou seja, o estado da base padrão
é repetido três vezes; observe em particular que isso não é a mesma coisa que repetir o estado quântico três vezes, como em um
estado quântico s sendo codificado como s tensor s tensor s, que não é uma codificação que seríamos capazes de
implementar para um estado quântico s desconhecido, pelo teorema da não-clonagem; a codificação de que estamos falando
por outro lado é muito facilmente implementada: aqui está um circuit quântico muito simples que faz isso usando dois qubits de espaço de trabalho inicializados e dois
gates controlled-NOT; agora vamos supor que um erro ocorre após a codificação ter sido
realizada e, em particular, vamos supor que uma operação Pauli X ou seja, um bit flip acontece em um dos
qubits — nesta figura é o qubit do meio; claro que esse não é o único tipo de erro que pode ocorrer e você pode
se opor à ideia de que um erro tem a forma dessa operação unitária perfeita, mas voltaremos a isso mais adiante na aula e por ora podemos
apenas pensar nisso como um exemplo; aqui está o estado resultante: é o mesmo que a codificação original, exceto
que o bit do meio dentro de cada ket foi invertido; obviamente podemos ver isso nas expressões matemáticas para o estado
mas suponha que tenhamos apenas os três qubits e que suspeitamos que um bit flip pode ter ocorrido, mas não sabemos em qual qubit pode ter sido
afetado; uma forma de descobrir se um bit flip ocorreu seria realizar uma medição na base padrão e examinar o resultado — nesse caso veríamos
010 ou 101 com probabilidades dependendo de Alpha e beta, e em ambos os casos nossa conclusão
seria que o bit do meio foi invertido; mas infelizmente isso arruína o estado quântico original e esse estado
pode ser precioso para nós — afinal, o objetivo é proteger esse estado quântico, portanto essa não é uma boa
opção; o que podemos fazer em vez disso é usar o circuit quântico mostrado aqui na tela, onde alimentamos o estado codificado
nos três qubits superiores; basicamente, o que o circuit faz é calcular a paridade dos
estados da base padrão para os dois qubits superiores, bem como para os dois qubits inferiores da codificação, e isso revelará a
localização do bit flip; em particular, nesse caso obteremos o resultado 1 para ambas essas verificações de paridade e com base em
essa informação podemos concluir que é o bit do meio que é diferente dos outros dois, portanto é evidentemente o que
foi invertido, e crucial mente isso não faz o estado colapsar, portanto agora temos a chance de tentar corrigir esse bit
flip para que eventualmente possamos talvez decodificar e recuperar nosso estado original; voltaremos à correção
em um momento, mas primeiro vamos considerar brevemente as outras possibilidades para um erro de bit flip; se em vez disso o erro de bit flip
ocorreu no qubit inferior ou esquerdo, então obteríamos o resultado 10 lendo de baixo para cima, e novamente
o estado não mudaria, e se o bit flip acontecesse com o qubit superior, então a saída seria
01, e mais uma vez o estado não muda; aliás, se não houve
nenhum erro de bit flip, então o resultado da medição é 00 e mais uma vez o estado sai inalterado
então vamos resumir tudo isso na forma de uma tabela onde listamos cada um dos possíveis estados que obtemos com no máximo um bit flip, os resultados da medição
que chamamos de síndrome no contexto da correção de erros, e a correção que precisamos fazer para recuperar a
codificação original; se não houve erro, a síndrome é 00 e nada precisa ser feito para corrigir o
estado; se o qubit inferior ou mais à esquerda experimentou um bit flip, a síndrome é 10 e a correção adequada
é aplicar um gate X ao qubit inferior ou mais à esquerda, e os outros dois casos são
similares; portanto, se aplicarmos a correção adequada com base na síndrome, teremos certeza de recuperar a
codificação original em todos os quatro casos; mais uma vez, estamos considerando apenas a possibilidade de que no máximo um bit
flip tenha ocorrido — isso não funcionaria corretamente se dois ou três bits fossem invertidos, e também não consideramos a
possibilidade de outros erros; agora vamos considerar um tipo diferente de erro: no cenário quântico, erros de bit
flip não são os únicos erros com os quais precisamos nos preocupar; por exemplo, também precisamos nos preocupar com erros de phase flip
ou apenas phase flips, que são descritos por gates Z ou equivalentemente operações Pauli Z
infelizmente, o código de repetição de três bits falha completamente em detectar phase flips; por exemplo, suponha que
codificamos um qubit usando o código de repetição de 3 bits como antes, e um erro de phase flip ocorre no
qubit do meio: obteremos o estado mostrado na tela, que é exatamente a codificação que teríamos obtido se um
phase flip tivesse acontecido no qubit original antes de codificarmos; portanto, se realizarmos o mesmo
circuit de antes para tentar detectar um erro, obteríamos a síndrome 00, o que sugere erroneamente que nenhum erro ocorreu
portanto, o código de repetição de 3 bits funciona para no máximo um erro de bit flip, mas falha em detectar erros de phase flip;
na verdade, piora as coisas de certa forma, pois agora temos três vezes mais qubits que podem potencialmente sofrer um phase flip
observamos que o código de repetição de três bits é completamente alheio a erros de phase flip, portanto não parece
ser muito útil para lidar com esse tipo de erro; mas na verdade podemos modificar o código de repetição de três bits de modo que ele
detecte erros de phase flip, e vou explicar agora como isso pode ser feito; aqui está o circuit original para
codificar um qubit usando o código de repetição de 3 bits, e a forma como o modificaremos é muito simples: apenas aplicamos um
gate Hadamard a cada qubit da codificação; um gate Hadamard transforma um estado zero em um estado plus e um
estado um em um estado minus, portanto o efeito líquido é que obtemos o estado mostrado na tela, onde |+++⟩
e |---⟩ são notações abreviadas para o tensor de três estados plus ou três estados minus
um erro de phase flip, ou seja, um gate Z, transforma estados plus em estados minus e estados minus em
estados plus; portanto, essa codificação será útil para detectar e corrigir erros de phase flip, e para fazer isso podemos
modificar o circuit de detecção de erros anterior da seguinte forma: aqui está o circuit de antes, e o que faremos é
simplesmente colocar gates Hadamard no início e no final, como mostrado na tela
a ideia é muito simples: os três primeiros gates Hadamard transformam os estados plus e minus de volta em estados zero e um; as
mesmas verificações de paridade de antes acontecem e depois a segunda camada de gates Hadamard nos leva de volta à nossa
codificação; outra forma de pensar nisso é que estamos basicamente apenas transformando erros de phase flip em erros de bit flip conjugando por operações Hadamard
aliás, podemos simplificar o circuit um pouco; este circuit aqui é completamente equivalente
e você pode verificar isso por conta própria se quiser; portanto, se colocarmos nosso qubit codificado nesse circuit supondo
que nenhum erro de phase flip tenha ocorrido, obtemos a síndrome 00, indicando que não houve phase flips
e se tivermos um erro de phase flip no qubit superior, por exemplo, então os plus e minus mais à direita se invertem
e isso resulta em uma síndrome de erro diferente: 01; nesse caso, isso identifica a localização do phase flip, assim como
tínhamos para o bit flip, e podemos corrigi-lo aplicando um gate Z ao qubit superior, e a situação
é similar para erros de phase flip em qualquer um dos outros dois qubits; portanto, podemos de fato detectar e
corrigir até um erro de phase flip usando esse código; mas, infelizmente, como você deve ter adivinhado, agora não conseguimos mais
corrigir erros de bit flip; nem tudo está perdido, porém, porque podemos de fato combinar esses dois códigos
para obter um código que pode corrigir tanto erros de bit flip quanto de phase flip, e na verdade ele será capaz de
corrigir qualquer erro em um único qubit; chegou a hora de discutir o código de Shor de 9 qubits, que é um código de correção de erros quânticos
que podemos obter combinando os dois códigos que acabamos de ver, ou seja, o código de repetição de três bits
que nos permite corrigir um único erro de bit flip e a versão modificada desse código que nos permite corrigir um único erro de phase flip
para ser mais preciso, o código de Shor de 9 qubits é o código que obtemos concatenando os dois códigos, o que significa
que primeiro aplicamos uma codificação que codifica um qubit em três e depois aplicamos a outra codificação a cada um dos
três qubits separadamente, portanto teremos nove qubits no total; podemos expressar isso na forma de
um diagrama de circuit da seguinte forma: primeiro aplicamos a versão modificada do código de repetição de 3 bits
que detecta erros de phase flip e depois codificamos cada um dos qubits resultantes independentemente usando o
código de repetição de 3 bits original; portanto, se reduzirmos um pouco esse circuit para liberar espaço, podemos
especificar o código em termos um pouco diferentes, descrevendo como os dois estados da base padrão do nosso qubit original são
codificados, e uma vez que saibamos disso, podemos determinar por linearidade como um vetor de estado de qubit arbitrário é
codificado; portanto, esse é o código de Shor de 9 qubits, e a ideia é que um dos códigos nos permite corrigir erros de phase flip
e o outro código nos permite corrigir erros de bit flip, e como veremos, isso de fato implicará que podemos
corrigir um erro arbitrário em um único qubit; agora vamos ver como podemos detectar e corrigir erros usando o código de Shor de 9 qubits
começando com erros de bit flip, que também são chamados de erros X; aqui está o circuit que realiza
a codificação, e só para facilitar a discussão, pensaremos nos nove qubits que obtemos desse código como sendo
agrupados em três blocos de três qubits, onde cada bloco representa a codificação que obtemos aplicando o
segundo passo de codificação, que é o código de repetição de 3 bits comum; esse é chamado de código interno nesse
contexto, enquanto o código externo é o código usado para o primeiro passo de codificação, que nesse caso é a versão modificada
do código de repetição de três bits que funciona para erros de phase flip; para corrigir erros de bit flip podemos
simplesmente tratar cada um dos blocos separadamente; cada bloco é uma codificação de um qubit usando o código de repetição de três bits
e esse código protege contra erros de bit flip; suponha primeiro que um erro X ocorra em qualquer um dos qubits
como o qubit do meio no bloco do meio; se verificarmos cada um dos blocos independentemente quanto a erros de bit flip e
corrigirmos os erros que encontrarmos, esse erro será corrigido e a codificação original será
recuperada; de fato, poderíamos ter até múltiplos erros X e ainda corrigi-los dessa forma, desde que os erros estejam
em blocos separados; se tivéssemos dois ou três erros X em um único bloco estaríamos com problemas, mas
desde que haja no máximo um erro X por bloco, o código interno irá capturá-los e seremos capazes de recuperar o estado codificado original
portanto, corrigir erros de bit flip é uma questão bastante simples para esse código; também precisamos considerar erros de phase flip
ou seja, erros Z; desta vez não é tão claro o que devemos fazer porque o código externo é o que
corrige erros de phase flip, mas não podemos detectá-los e corrigi-los diretamente porque o código interno está de certa forma
no caminho; mas veremos como fazer isso em breve; para entender melhor como erros X e Z
funcionam e os efeitos que têm dentro de circuits quânticos, é útil observar algumas relações simples entre esses erros e gates controlled-NOT
e isso também será útil em uma aula posterior; primeiro, vamos começar com erros X
ou gates X e como eles se relacionam com gates C-NOT; se aplicarmos um gate X ao
qubit alvo de um C-NOT e depois aplicarmos o C-NOT, isso é equivalente a trocar a ordem e fazer o C-NOT
primeiro; por outro lado, se aplicarmos um gate X ao qubit de controle de um C-NOT e depois aplicarmos o C-NOT, não podemos simplesmente
trocar a ordem, mas em vez disso temos que aplicar o gate X a ambos os qubits, e você pode verificar todas essas relações por
conta própria se quiser, pensando no que acontece com estados da base padrão, por exemplo; a situação é similar para erros Z
exceto que os papéis dos qubits de controle e alvo se invertem; em particular, se realizarmos um
gate Z no qubit de controle de um C-NOT e depois realizarmos o C-NOT, isso tem o mesmo efeito que realizar o
gate Z após o C-NOT; mas se realizarmos o gate Z no qubit alvo em vez disso, então isso é
equivalente a primeiro realizar o C-NOT e depois aplicar um gate Z a ambos os qubits; e finalmente, todas essas
relações são simétricas no sentido de que podemos sempre trocar a ordem dos gates em ambos os lados de cada equação
o que é equivalente a tomar o inverso ou o transposto conjugado de ambos os lados, dado que gates X, Z e C-NOT
são todos seus próprios inversos; agora vamos considerar erros de phase flip e como podemos detectá-los e corrigi-los
usando o código de Shor de 9 qubits; aqui está nosso circuit de codificação e continuaremos a pensar nos nove
qubits usados na codificação como sendo agrupados em três blocos de três qubits; suponha que um erro Z ocorra em
qualquer um dos qubits, como o indicado aqui; usando o que acabamos de observar sobre gates Z
e gates C-NOT, isso é equivalente a dois erros Z anteriores ao C-NOT: um no
controle e um no qubit alvo; e esses erros comutam com o outro C-NOT no bloco, portanto podemos
trocar a ordem e aqui está o que obtemos; o erro Z inferior não faz nada porque está atuando em um estado zero
e podemos deslizar todo o resto para obter este diagrama; portanto, o que descobrimos é que um erro Z em algum lugar dentro
do bloco do meio é equivalente a um erro Z ocorrendo no qubit do meio antes da segunda fase de codificação, e
você pode raciocinar exatamente da mesma forma para um erro Z em qualquer um dos qubits; um phase flip em qualquer qubit dentro de um bloco
é equivalente a um phase flip no qubit correspondente antes da codificação interna, e isso é bastante direto e intuitivo se você
pensar em como erros Z afetam o código de repetição de três bits; portanto, uma opção para lidar com um erro Z
é decodificar o código interno e depois detectar e corrigir erros Z usando o código externo, que é a versão modificada
do código de repetição de 3 bits que pode corrigir um erro Z; assim corrigimos nosso erro Z e
podemos recodificar com o código interno se quisermos; também podemos corrigir erros Z no próprio lugar
sem decodificar e recodificar, e é bastante simples, mas para explicar como podemos
fazer isso precisaremos de um pouco mais de espaço; suponha que decodifiquemos o código interno
e depois calculemos a síndrome para o código externo usando o mesmo método de antes, onde envolvemos apenas os três qubits do código externo, e
depois recodificamos; bem, podemos simplificar todos esses C-NOTs um pouco e de fato
podemos usar as relações entre gates NOT e gates C-NOT que observamos há pouco para ajudar com essa
tarefa, e fazendo isso podemos economizar quatro C-NOTs, e este é o circuit que obtemos; se um erro Z ocorreu em um dos
qubits, o que a síndrome nos diz agora não é qual qubit sofreu um erro Z, mas sim em qual bloco o erro Z
ocorreu; mas está tudo bem porque sabemos que não importa qual qubit dentro de um bloco sofre um erro Z — o
efeito é o mesmo para todos os três qubits dentro desse bloco, portanto podemos de fato corrigir o erro Z aplicando um gate Z a qualquer um dos
qubits dentro desse bloco; esse, aliás, é um exemplo do que se chama degenerescência em um código de correção de erros
onde não identificamos unicamente um dado erro, mas somos capazes de corrigi-lo assim mesmo; finalmente, vamos supor que tanto um
bit flip quanto um phase flip ocorram, possivelmente no mesmo qubit; por exemplo, vamos supor que um
bit flip e um phase flip aconteçam neste qubit aqui; acontece que esses erros podem ser
detectados e corrigidos completamente de forma independente, e na verdade não importa se corrigimos cada bloco para um
bit flip primeiro e depois corrigimos para phase flips ou se fazemos o contrário; para ver isso, vamos primeiro observar
que a ordem desses erros não importa, então podemos invertê-los se quisermos; o motivo disso não é porque
X e Z comutam, porque não comutam — X * Z é igual a menos Z * X — mas o
fator -1 não tem efeito nessa situação porque é uma fase global; agora podemos mover o erro Z como
antes, e nesse ponto fica evidente que se primeiro corrigíssemos cada bloco para erros X e depois corrigíssemos
para erros Z, teríamos corrigido ambos os erros; alternativamente, se por algum motivo
decidíssemos corrigir os erros Z primeiro, poderíamos fazer isso e o erro X não teria absolutamente nenhum efeito nesse processo
isso tem que ser verdade porque, primeiro, o erro X comuta com todos os gates no circuit que calcula a
síndrome para o código externo, e segundo, a ordem entre o erro X e o gate Z que aplicamos para fazer a
correção não importa, assim como argumentamos quando o gate Z era um erro; portanto, isso permite a correção do erro Z
e podemos depois corrigir cada bloco para eliminar o erro X; portanto, o que argumentamos é que podemos
corrigir um erro X, um erro Z ou ambos em qualquer um dos qubits usando esse código
na verdade, podemos corrigir mais erros do que isso, como múltiplos erros X desde que estejam em blocos diferentes
ou múltiplos erros Z desde que no máximo um bloco tenha um número ímpar deles; mas daqui para frente o que será mais relevante
é que podemos corrigir um erro X, um erro Z ou ambos em qualquer qubit, e na última parte da aula
veremos como isso é de fato suficiente para concluir que esse código pode corrigir um erro arbitrário em qualquer qubit
antes de prosseguirmos para a última parte da aula, na qual consideraremos erros quânticos arbitrários, vamos brevemente
considerar o desempenho do código de Shor de 9 qubits quando erros representados por matrizes de Pauli ocorrem aleatoriamente nos
qubits; para ser mais concreto, vamos considerar um modelo de ruído simples onde erros ocorrem independentemente nos qubits
com cada qubit sofrendo um erro com probabilidade p e sem correlação entre erros em qubits diferentes
o pior caso para o código de Shor de 9 qubits é que um erro Y — ou seja, tanto um erro X quanto um erro Z —
ocorra em cada qubit afetado, e vamos assumir esse pior caso apenas para obter um limite
no desempenho do código; mas você poderia também considerar, por exemplo, que os três erros de Pauli são igualmente
prováveis; agora suponha que Q é um qubit em algum estado particular que gostaríamos de proteger contra erros e imagine que
temos a opção de usar o código de Shor de 9 qubits — devemos usá-lo? bem, a resposta não é necessariamente
sim, porque se houver muito ruído ou seja, se p for grande demais, usar o código de Shor poderia na verdade piorar as coisas
assim como aconteceu com o código de repetição quando p é maior que 1/2; mas se p for pequeno o suficiente, então a
resposta é sim, devemos usar o código; então vamos ver por que isso é e o que significa p ser grande ou pequeno demais
para esse código; o código de Shor pode corrigir qualquer erro de Pauli em um único qubit e no pior
caso, onde os erros de Pauli são erros Y, isso significa que o código protege Q com êxito com probabilidade dada pela
expressão mostrada na tela; especificamente, o código funciona quando não há erros e isso acontece
com probabilidade (1-p)^9, porque há nove qubits que devem cada um ser sem erros, e funciona quando há
exatamente um erro; e considerando que há nove qubits diferentes que podem ser afetados, isso acontece com probabilidade 9 * P * (1-p)^8
por outro lado, se não nos preocuparmos em usar o código, nosso único qubit não seria afetado por um erro com
probabilidade 1 menos P; portanto, o código só ajuda quando a primeira probabilidade é maior que a segunda
porque essas expressões representam nossas probabilidades de sucesso nos dois casos: quando usamos o código e quando
não usamos; aqui está um gráfico dessas duas funções para valores pequenos de p e descobrimos que o ponto de equilíbrio ocorre em
cerca de 3 e 3/4 por cento; portanto, se p for menor que esse valor, o código
ajuda; no ponto de equilíbrio as probabilidades são iguais, portanto estamos apenas desperdiçando nosso tempo além de 8 qubits se
usarmos o código; mas fora isso não há problema e além desse ponto definitivamente não devemos usar esse código
porque na verdade está aumentando a chance de um erro no qubit codificado, ao qual normalmente nos referimos como o
qubit lógico nesse contexto, e isso acontece simplesmente porque a chance de dois ou mais erros em nove qubits é
maior que a chance de um erro em um único qubit para valores de p nessa faixa; 3 e 3/4% pode não parecer muito
bom particularmente quando comparado a 50%, que é o ponto de equilíbrio análogo para o código de repetição de três bits para
informação clássica; mas é mais difícil proteger informação quântica e, além disso, embora esse
código represente uma descoberta brilhante como o primeiro código de correção de erros quânticos, e seja ótimo para fins pedagógicos, o fato é
que ele simplesmente não é um código tão bom em termos práticos; até agora consideramos erros X
e erros Z no contexto do código de Shor de 9 qubits; agora vamos considerar erros arbitrários
começando primeiro com erros unitários; por exemplo, tal erro poderia corresponder a uma rotação muito pequena
da esfera de Bloch, possivelmente representando um erro incorrido por um gate que não é perfeito, por exemplo
ou poderia ser qualquer outra operação unitária em um qubit e não necessariamente algo próximo à operação identidade
pode parecer difícil corrigir tais erros — há infinitos erros possíveis como
esses, e é inconcebível que possamos de alguma forma identificar exatamente qual erro é e depois desfazê-lo; mas
não precisamos fazer nada diferente do que já discutimos: desde que possamos corrigir um bit flip, um phase flip ou ambos, então
de fato conseguiremos corrigir um erro unitário arbitrário em um único qubit, e vou agora explicar por que isso é assim
primeiro, como toda matriz 2x2, podemos expressar uma matriz unitária arbitrária
representando um erro em um único qubit como uma combinação linear das quatro matrizes de Pauli, incluindo a matriz identidade
e aliás, como você pode ter notado, estou usando X, Y e Z maiúsculos para denotar as matrizes de Pauli não-identidade
e continuarei fazendo isso pelo restante desta série; isso é convencional na correção de erros quânticos e também
facilita um pouco a leitura nesse contexto; também será conveniente usar subscritos para indicar em qual
qubit uma dada operação unitária de qubit atua; portanto, por exemplo, se usarmos a
convenção de numeração de qubits do Qiskit começando pelo qubit zero à direita, então temos as expressões mostradas na tela para
várias operações unitárias em qubits individuais, onde em cada caso fazemos o produto tensorial da matriz unitária com a matriz identidade
em todos os outros qubits; portanto, em particular, podemos expressar U_k significando U aplicado ao qubit K como a mesma
combinação linear de antes, exceto que cada matriz de Pauli é aplicada ao qubit K; não precisamos nos preocupar com o
subscrito para a identidade, aliás — o entendimento aqui é que essa é a identidade em todos os
qubits; agora suponha que |ψ⟩ é a codificação de 9 qubits de um estado de qubit; se o erro U acontece ao
qubit k, então obtemos U_k|ψ⟩, que podemos expressar como uma combinação linear de operações de Pauli atuando em |ψ⟩, que claro
é apenas |ψ⟩ no caso da identidade; nesse ponto será útil observar que a matriz Y de Pauli
é igual a i * X * Z, portanto podemos fazer essa substituição em nossa
expressão; esse erro ocorreu e agora suponha que tentemos corrigi-lo usando o mesmo procedimento de
antes; o primeiro passo é calcular a síndrome, que no caso do código de Shor tem 8 bits de comprimento — dois bits para cada uma das
três vezes que usamos o código interno, junto com dois bits adicionais para o código externo; mas isso realmente não importa, podemos apenas pensar nisso como
uma string de comprimento fixo; aqui está uma descrição do estado que obtemos logo antes da medição da síndrome, onde cada
síndrome são os oito bits que obtemos do erro de Pauli correspondente; observe nesse ponto que os dois
sistemas estão correlacionados em geral, e esse realmente é o segredo para fazer tudo isso funcionar; ao medir a síndrome, o que
efetivamente faremos é colapsar o estado para um em que uma das quatro operações de Pauli foi aplicada ao
qubit k de |ψ⟩, e saberemos pela síndrome qual operação de Pauli foi, para que possamos corrigi-la, se
necessário; em particular, se medirmos a síndrome e fizermos a correção apropriada, então obtemos um estado do
formato mostrado na tela, que criticamente é um estado produto; temos nossa codificação original não corrompida como o
fator tensorial da direita, que é o mais importante aqui, e à esquerda temos uma matriz de densidade σ que
descreve uma síndrome de erro aleatória, mas não há mais nenhuma correlação com o sistema que nos importa, que é
o da direita, porque os erros foram corrigidos; nesse ponto podemos descartar os qubits da síndrome ou redefini-los
caso queiramos usá-los novamente, e isso é de fato bastante importante porque é assim que a aleatoriedade ou entropia
gerada por erros é removida do sistema, e é assim que a discretização de erros funciona, pelo menos para erros unitários
em essência, ao medir a síndrome, projetamos efetivamente o erro em um erro descrito por
uma matriz de Pauli; à primeira vista pode parecer bom demais para ser verdade que podemos corrigir erros unitários arbitrários
como este, mesmo erros que são minúsculos e quase imperceptíveis por conta própria; mas o que é importante perceber aqui
é que este é um erro unitário em um único qubit, e pelo design do código, uma operação em um único qubit não pode mudar o
estado do qubit lógico que está sendo codificado; tudo que pode fazer é mover o estado para fora do espaço de codificações válidas
mas as correções o trazem de volta ao lugar onde estava; finalmente, vamos considerar o que acontece
quando ocorre um erro arbitrário, não necessariamente unitário; a configuração é a mesma de antes:
codificamos um qubit em 9 usando o código de Shor e algum erro arbitrário representado por um canal de qubit φ
ocorre em um dos qubits; como veremos, tudo vai funcionar de maneira bastante parecida
com o que aconteceu para erros unitários, e o primeiro passo para verificar isso é considerar uma representação de Kraus do nosso
erro; o que podemos fazer agora é seguir exatamente o mesmo raciocínio de antes para erros unitários, exceto que aplicamos esse
raciocínio às matrizes de Kraus em vez de a uma única matriz unitária representando um erro
em particular, cada matriz de Kraus pode ser expressa como uma combinação linear de matrizes de Pauli, e isso nos permite
expressar a ação desse erro φ em qualquer qubit K na forma mostrada aqui na
tela; tudo que estamos fazendo aqui é expandir as matrizes de Kraus como combinações lineares de matrizes de Pauli
se então calcularmos e medirmos a síndrome de erro e corrigirmos quaisquer erros que sejam revelados, obteremos um
estado similar ao que tivemos no caso de um erro unitário; não vou passar pelos detalhes — é tudo bastante similar ao caso unitário
e também um pouco mais confuso de escrever, mas conceitualmente é bastante
direto; devo mencionar que tudo isso se generaliza para outros códigos de correção de erros quânticos, incluindo códigos que podem corrigir erros em múltiplos
qubits; nesse caso, erros em múltiplos qubits podem ser expressos como combinações lineares de produtos tensoriais de matrizes de Pauli
e correspondentemente as diferentes síndromes possíveis descreverão correções que são realizadas em múltiplos qubits em vez de apenas um
qubit; mas a ideia subjacente é exatamente a mesma; mais uma vez, medindo a síndrome
projetamos ou colapsamos efetivamente os erros em um conjunto discreto de possibilidades representadas por produtos tensoriais
de matrizes de Pauli, e corrigindo esses erros — ou seja, os erros de Pauli — podemos recuperar o estado
codificado original; enquanto isso, qualquer aleatoriedade gerada no processo é transferida para os qubits de síndrome, que podemos então
descartar ou redefinir, o que é crucial porque é assim que a entropia gerada por erros e medições de síndrome é
removida do sistema; e esse é o final da aula em que demos uma primeira olhada na
correção de erros quânticos, incluindo o código de Shor de 9 qubits e a discretização de erros; espero que você se junte a mim para a
próxima aula, na qual discutiremos o formalismo do estabilizador, que nos fornece uma ferramenta poderosa para descrever e
analisar uma classe grande e interessante de códigos de correção de erros quânticos, incluindo aqueles que são candidatos promissores para
computadores quânticos reais; até a próxima